anyways we're moving him to hospice care
can't even process my own emotions
because there's so much to do bro ready
for a hot take
um dying low-key sucks it's not a hot
take that's just a statement everyone
these days thinks having an opinion is a
hot take how about this Star Wars
episode one is low-key the best of the
prequel trilogy except for episode three
obviously so it's better than one other
movie Hot take Indiana Jones four was
not that bad you know it does get too
much hate I always thought it was kind
of fun well if it's so easy why don't
you try huh what's your hot take Mr hot
take I don't go around just cataloging
hot takes in my head all right well
here's one let's hear it you are a
terrible person
all right now that's I guess that counts
also I want you to stop hanging out with
me bro hot take I don't like you I hang
out with you because I feel bad that you
have no friends
now that is a hot take bro
ouch being serious oh okay yeah